The Joe Rogan experience,
I just had the worst massage thing.
I'm,
I think I'm done now.
I was in Santa Monica and it was like,
I was trying to think carefully if you want to say this on the area.
Yeah,
it's fine.
But I was actually thinking like I'll just get a legitimate savage.
This place was open really late though and it,
but it looked really nice outside or you know,
so I was like,
uh,
are you open?
And I think they might've just sent the last girl home because I saw this pretty
decent looking girl.
Walk out the side door.
And then Tom,
is it 9:30?
Really for the most part,
no legit massages happening after 9:30.
Why would say it's like most of the massage places closed down around nine.
Yeah.
But this was the right down the street from Bolus.
I'm like,
all right,
can't be too crazy all.
So,
uh,
I go in and this really old fat Asian lady was there and I was like,
are you open?
And she's like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I go in the room and I now just always take all my clothes off.
I don't even keep boxers on all the time now just in case if,
you know,
the girls is really high.
That's cool,
you know,
but I just wanted to real massage and then she walks in wearing like a dress,
no underwear,
nice and like cut really short and just fat and old,
like,
like a grandma old lady and she was dressed up like totally changed clothes.
I heard somebody go to the bathroom so that means she went into the bathroom,
washed herself,
you know,
and stuff like that because she smelled like this perfume and then she shot,
she gets on top of me,
removes the towel,
gets on top of me and just kept on bouncing like I hurt a vagina was like all my
butthole,
like it was just on.
Yeah,
me just bouncing and it's like not really massage or anything,
shaved it.
I don't think so.
I think I was freaked out and so I was just like,
play dead,
play dead.
Like don't even like don't make a noise.
I'm thinking like,
oh,
I hope she really gets off me if she could start massage me.
So suddenly she starts rubbing her hands on my back and her shit calluses or
something because it just scratch and it was,
it hurt though,
like it felt like she was like stabbing me,
like hurry closely,
like so I'm just like,
ah.
And then like she flips me over eventually and stuff like that.
At any point where you're like,
I'm going to just leave.
I know.
No,
because I didn't want to be rude and I thought she was.
She was kind of trying and then she,
oh she started playing with my butt and stuff.
Like a lot of places give you prostate massagers and I'm trying to like tighten
it up.
That's funny statements.
Anybody ever say a lot of places give you prostate?
It's pretty popular compared to what I'm really good now at like what you said,
like when I'm uncomfortable,
like shit like that I wouldn't be bad at leaving,
but like now I walked out of movies.
I walked out of massage.
Really?
You just get up.
I'm just like,
I'm not into this anymore and I just get up and I leave.
I've done that yet it ended really bad and then when she flipped me over she
just kept on like touching my dick and I'm like,
no,
like this and stuff like that.
And then she finally gave up and then left and then came in and like,
you didn't get hard for her?
No,
I couldn't.
I seriously,
I didn't.
I was so grossed out.
I was like freaking out with had my eyes because like,
how many times have you been back?
I've never get back that.
How many times have you jerked off thinking about it?
Never.
She's not in my spank bank.
It was too gross.
My Bank bank,
there's a massage place by my house.
Which the.
Listen,
let's not name names.
No,
no,
no.
I live.
I live in Korea town.
Oh cool.
And I,
I've been going to this place for over 10 years.
You know,
they have young girls.
No,
it's a,
it's not a sex place.
It's a complete legitimate massage place.
And like Joe,
when I go to a place when it's like some white chick or something,
it's not a good massage.
You go to the Thai place or you go to the Korean place where they look like your
mother fucking rip your Shit Up.
Do they go fucking crazy?
Like you know they give you,
they get in there,
they stand on your back,
they pound your shit and yeah,
afterwards you feel all spelt and nice and flowy.
Whatever is boxing gym in Burbank.
There's a massage parlor that's connected to.
No,
no,
no.
That's legit.
Legit massage.
So this is a place I've been going to for 10 years.
Not that much,
but you know,
every time I know that I just want a regular massage,
I know that some chick that looks like my mom or my aunt is going to give me a
great massage and then I'm done.
You know?
So I.
But I haven't been back for a few.
I moved to New York,
whatever.
And my way of dealing with that whole thing with me puking before going on shows
is I started getting massages and I like hard ones.
I'm like,
it has to be a hard deep tissue,
and I was like,
I'm going to go back to that place,
and so I already told this story,
but I'll tell it quick it,
it's the same story as yours,
although it's 9:30 or 10.
All the,
the,
you know,
they're not ugly,
but they're just older and it's just.
The Mama saw the.
She's like,
I'm like,
oh,
I'll just come back.
And she's like,
no,
just come,
come in.
And I'm like,
okay.
Never once even thought that I was going to get a hand job,
you know,
I get in there,
she comes in and then I'm like,
oh,
the fucking lady,
the receptionist is giving me.
And I'm like,
all right,
cool.
Amazing massage cracks my neck cracking sounds back,
just fucking doing it.
And then,
uh,
you know,
she flips me over and starts jerking me off and I'm like,
oh,
that's what I thought when I came in.
It was always like a $40 massage place,
like a cheap Korean massage and then it was $75 now or something like that.
I was like,
what?
A $30 increase in like,
what the fuck is that?
That's a bargain and a half,
you know,
if you like what?
Could they be doing different?
Maybe it's an intense tax.
No,
maybe it's scented candles that they have to pay.
She flips me over and,
and,
and she goes like,
like she just does a couple of ball flicks,
like do you want this?
And I was like,
I was like,
no,
but I was like,
yeah,
like,
no.
But you were like,
yeah.
And I like 12.
Yeah,
exactly it all.
And I'm like.
And I was like,
Brian,
I was like,
there's no way I'm going to get hard.
But because she's a professional.
Yeah,
she was whatever.
She did lots of hot oil.
Wow.
I'm like,
whoa.
And then I'm pretty sure this is a massage parlor for Paul.
That thing,
the bell from someone else coming in.
Hello,
is someone in here?
She goes,
okay,
wait,
so sure.
Tops.
Mid Jerk.
She stops and I hear,
you know,
it's like a small place.
So I hear their whole conversation.
He's like,
hey,
it's Rachel or Jenny working tonight.
It's like,
no,
everyone go home,
wait 10 minutes,
maybe five minutes,
and I,
and I get into the guys,
you could tell.
He's like,
no,
stay,
I give you a discount.
I give you a $10 discount.
And he's like,
Eh,
and I'm sitting there and my bone or just going and I'm like,
because you're seeing her actively be rejected.
It's bad on both fronts and just.
And just like,
I got a break.
I'm like,
I could cut out right now,
right.
I'm like,
I should leave.
And then the negotiation is like,
he's one foot out the door.
He's like,
I don't know.
no,
come in,
I'll be done in five,
four,
three minutes.
I'll be finished three minutes.
And I'm like,
I'm like,
I'm going to get up.
Okay,
I'm going to count to 10 in my head right now,
title nine,
when I get this one,
I'm going to walk out the door.
So I started sitting up and then she,
the guys like,
I'm going to go and he left and she runs back in and she goes,
laid out and I go,
okay,
so laid out and now I'm deflated.
I'm like,
I said,
it's okay.
I'm just going to go.
And she goes,
no,
no.
And she starts up again and now she's just playing with my wet noodle.
It's not like there's too much thought in and I go,
stop right there.
Is there a Saturday moment in life?
No.
It's tugging on your deck and you don't want them to.
I'm like,
it's done.
It's cool.
She got this lady's fit and it's a dark room.
She doesn't give off.
She's a trained,
trained assassin.
She wasn't even worried for a second.
She was okay.
Okay.
She reaches up behind her and tears a piece of Saran wrap and I go,
what's going to happen now?
I don't know what this is right now.
And she fucking like put some shit on my ass.
Some Lube.
And she's like,
puts the,
she,
she holds my legs up like this and taft's my legs like,
like hold your legs.
And I'm like,
okay.
So I'm holding my legs like this and I go,
I don't know what's going to happen right now,
but I'm going for it.
She puts the Saran wrap over my butthole and I go,
she's gonna Lick my ass right now.
Like through the Saran wrap
to this day,
besides the part where when I was a kid that I put a vacuum cleaner on my
butthole.
I've never felt this before.
She didn't stick her tongue into my butthole.
She sucked my butthole.
She put her lips around my butthole and sucked.
And I was like never felt that before.
Dick tickets hard immediately.
A few seconds just shot a load without even jerking off.
No,
she jerked me off.
It was like how much time between her putting the Saran wrap over your butt hole
and you're shooting a load.
How much time?
Fifteen seconds to put the Saran wrap.
Got Five seconds to shoot.
She was immediately like.
I was like,
I've heard of girls putting their finger up a guy's bud and licking it and she
sucked the bottle.
She sucked my butthole.
So I'm filled with so much shame.
I'm like,
she's like,
you know,
she just throws the towel on me.
He's like,
okay,
cool.
And I'm like,
you know,
business lady,
when she goes to the supermarket and she buys the Saran wrapped as the lady,
know what she's going to use it for when she brings it home in.
The kids are like,
grandma,
why you buy so much Saran wrap every week?
Like,
oh my God,
I,
I go in the car and I go,
I can never talk about this day.
And then,
I mean,
it was a dare you lie to yourself.
Well,
unlike Brian,
I've been back several times now.
So where is this again?
You're a fucking human being.